okay let's try and pull together all of
this research I've been doing both on
physical places in which people live and
work but their oral places ie the music
they listen to and the virtual spaces
such as their Facebook profiles and it
seemed like this would be a good
opportunity to pull it together
the idea behind snoop is that is that
the places which we select and craft are
rich with clues about what we're like
and so the question is what can you
learn about someone by going into their
environment what can you learn about
them and we certainly form lots of
impressions which one's the which of
those impressions are accurate which
ones are inaccurate what are people
learning about us and even more broadly
and this is I think sort of the the
intellectual kernel really interests me
is how are we connected to our spaces
and I think we often don't realize it
cuz so automatic we just say oh I like
that photo and put the photo up but but
we didn't just put that photo up it will
we there were 10,000 photos we could
have put up we put that one up why do we
put it up and and what can that teachers
about how we are connected to the spaces
basically having to be you know and I
think that's to be one of the palings I
think that they you know architects see
themselves generally as artists and they
are doing their project and you may be
lucky enough to live in one of their
magnificent creations but and and those
those people in the building trade who
have really gone and asked people what
they want and looked at what people want
they are with with division referred to
as builders by architects their builders
that's not the proper thing but but
there are some people who are doing it
and one of these people is is Chris
Travis who who really goes very deeply
into people's psychology and where their
their associations with buildings and
environments come from so right at the
very beginning before he's even started
work he does that and it turns out that
that's a tremendously effective both
from his perspective and also the the
clients is it's effective from his
perspective because because he gets the
design right so in in nearly in 90% of
the cases after he's gone through this
interview which takes a long long time
and all these psychological exercises he
comes up with the design and he nails it
the first time and so much of
architectural work comes about from from
doing redesigns okay here's one design
okay we have to redo it and redo it and
he finds in now he won't even take on
clients who won't go through this
process because he said it's too
expensive for him not to he can't afford
to go through all that redesign so so
that he seems to nail the design every
time and I've went to a few of his
houses and they're really quite
different there's not like he just has
hit the key they and they're really
molded to people and and I spoke to a
lot of his clients and it is really
interesting they they talk about the
place and they say it just fits us we
love it but at the same time was
interesting if they seem to be largely
unaware that the psychological interview
had any role in it I mean they went
through III couldn't but I couldn't
believe
Chris Travers told me but he said look
people are very resistant to believing
that they're under underlying sort of
psychological needs played into this but
but but it results in his building I
couldn't believe it until I saw them and
spoke with them and they and they were
you know and I and so I know they have
gone through this into view and and then
Travis has designed a place based on
that so I was saying so I was asking
them how does it relate and they go I
just like the places there's no it
doesn't have anything to do with that it
was really astonishing and Travis bleeds
you know people don't like it freaks
people out
to feel so they're of these sort of
forces they don't know about controlling
what they do